Transcriber: Anjelika Eda Erdem
Gözden geçirme: Ebrar Batmaz
Bugün yansıttıklarımızdan çokça bahsettik.
Ben de farklı bir noktaya
değinmek istedim.
O da yansıtamadıklarımız.
Nedir bu yansıtamadıklarımız?
Duygularımızı, düşüncelerimizi
ve hislerimizi
bazen tam olarak yansıtamayız
ya da yansıtmak istemeyiz.
Bununla beraber yansıtamadıklarımız
içimizde bir baskıya neden olabilir.
Öyle dışarı açamadığımız şeylere
neden olduğundan dolayı da
kendimizi kapatabiliriz içimize doğru.
Ayrıca bunu sosyal medyada
çokça görebiliriz.
Mesela sosyal medyada tam olarak
her şeyi açıkça yansıtamayız.
Örnek bir olay verecek olursam,
bir gün bir grup düşünelim.
Arkadaşlarla beraber yemeğe gidiyorlar
ve ardından
işte herkes,
çok yemekler geliyor, içecekler içiliyor.
Herkes çok ciddi bir şekilde,
telefonlarına dönük bir şekilde
yemeklerini yedikten sonra
birisi diyor ki:
“Gelin bu anı ölümsüzleştirelim
ve bir fotoğraf çekilelim.”
Çekiyorlar.
Ama o fotoğrafı çekerken o kadar mutlular
ki, en mutlu oldukları top nokta orası.
Ondan sonrasında tabii fotoğraf çekiliyor,
ardından tekrardan geriye
mutsuzlukları kalıyor onlara.
Peki sizce sosyal medyada biz kendimizi
tam olarak yansıtabiliyor muyuz?
Bunu aslında kendimize
her zaman sormak gerekli.
Sosyal medyada açıkçası
her zaman kendimizi
yansıtamadığımız taraftarıyım ben.
Çünkü kendimizde yanlış noktalarımızı
ya da düzeltmemiz gereken noktaları
her zaman düzeltiyoruz.
Ya da direkt sosyal medyaya
yansıtmıyoruz bu yönlerimizi.
Mesela bir olay gelecek.
Mesela, bir sözden bahsedeyim ben,
benim çok hoşuma giden.
“Sosyal medya bizi mutsuzluğa
sürüklemiyor.
Mutsuzluk, sosyal medya isteğimizi,
isteğimizi, ihtiyacımızı hissettiriyor.”
Ne kadar doğru, ne kadar anlamlı bir söz
aslında içine bakıldıkça.
Çünkü sosyal medya, ne kadar
sosyal medya kendimize
kendimizi yansıtmamız gereken
bir yer olduğu düşünsek de,
bazen yansıtmamız, yansıtmamamız
gerektiğini de düşünebiliyoruz
aynı zamanda.
Ben de açıkçası bu sözü burada
açıklamak istedim.
Şimdi, toplumumuzda da
bazen yansıtmadığımız
ya da yansıtamadığımız
bir kavram var.
Hatta zaman zaman bu kavramda da
çeşitli duygular göz ardı edilebiliyor.
Nedir bu duygu?
Sevgimizi yansıtamama.
Sevgimizi yansıtamama nedir?
Dışarıya tam olarak sevgimizi vuramama,
ne kadar içte birisine karşı
ya da bir şeye karşı
ne kadar hisli olsak da
dışarıya bazen tam olarak
o hissimizi yansıtamıyoruz tam olarak.
Bununla birlikte bir tane
doktorun bir sözü var.
Şöyle diyor bir doktor:
“Sevgi, paylaştıkça çoğalır.
Hem veren hem alan sevgiden aynı zamanda,
sevgiyi aynı zamanda hissedebilir.”
Açıkçası bu söz bana, bu söz
bana da çok mantıklı geliyor.
Çünkü sevgi paylaştıkça çoğalan bir şey
ve paylaştıkça artan da bir şey aslında.
Birbirlerini hissederler,
birbirimizi hissederiz.
Daha doğrusu birbirimizi anlarız.
Empati duygumuz gelişir burada.
Bana göre.
Bununla beraber, bana göre,
ben neden yansıtamadıklarımızı seçtim
birazcık ondan da bahsedeyim.
Hayatımızda her zaman
yansıttığımız şeyler olur.
Ama bir çoğumuz dışarıya
yansıtamadığımız şeyleri,
içimizde yaşarız aslında
çok yoğun duygularla.
Bazen çok soru işaretleri olur
kafamızın içerisinde.
Deriz acaba bunu dışarıya aktarsak mı
ya da aktarmasak mı ?
Bazen de deriz, aktarmamak
en iyisi ya da aktarayım
insanlar da bilmiş olsun
benim ne düşündüklerimi.
Ben de bugün yansıtamadıklarımızı,
‘Yansıtamadıklarımız’ adlı başlığa değinip
geniş derinliklerde olan o cevherleri
çıkarmaya çalıştım aslında.
Ne kadar yansıtabilsek de bazı şeyleri,
bazı şeyleri de yansıtmamak
her zaman insanın
lehine olabiliyor,
lehine sonuçlanabiliyor.
Açıkçası bunu insanoğlu her zaman
deneyimlerinden
ve davranışlarına göre karar verebilir.
Ne kadar deneyimlerse, ne kadar
olaydan sonuç çıkartırsa,
o kadar fazla da bilebilir, görebilir.
Benim konuşmam bu kadardı.
Çok teşekkür ediyorum herkese!
Umarım keyifle dinlemişsinizdir.
Öyle söyleyeyim.
Çok teşekkürler, çok sağ olun!